we're taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
we're going to go to our next caller a
color what's your name and where are you
calling from hey baby Vance me I'm
calling in from all the better what's on
your mind well we kind of about how the
Republicans blocked Obama's ability to
fill the Supreme Court seat and I'm just
wondering what your thoughts are on
maybe the Democrats going forward
blocking Trump from filling that seat
the entire term or saying that Obama
even though he's no longer the president
can opt in and fill the seat at any time
well obviously they're not going to say
Obama can come in and fill the seat I
mean that just doesn't make any sense
now the question would be would there be
any way for Democrats to block Trump
from filling the seat when he's
president the argument from Republicans
was because Obama is in the last year of
his presidency we should wait for the
next election to happen before we feel
the sea it's ridiculous right I mean
President Obama was elected to be
president until january twentieth of
2017 so the initial argument made for
not filling the seat is a crazy argument
I think it's absolutely deplorable the
problem is who's going to stop Trump
from filling the seat is going to have
the Republican House a Republican Senate
they are the ones who will decide
whether to hold the confirmation
hearings so I don't see any practical
way to prevent Trump from filling the
seat that Donald that President Obama
had proposed Merrick garland for I don't
see any way that that it doesn't happen
under Trump yeah I'm not exactly sure
what are the numbers that the
Republicans me well they have the actual
vote yes as far as I know they will have
no problem getting the hearing started
and once once you do that i mean it is
insanely rare that once you have
confirmation hearings that the Supreme
Court justice ultimately is not
confirmed to the Supreme Court it's
insanely rare and I just don't see how
Democrats would have any leverage to
push that yeah I've heard of Chuck
Schumer kind of teasing the idea but I
kind of feel like he's just another
corporate guy who
you know it's probably looking to run
probably trying to get through the
burning board oh yeah I don't think you
get it in a way of a trump appointing
anybody to Supreme Court good question
wishful thinking I don't think we're
going to see anything at all notable
about that thanks so much for the call i
really do appreciate it